doing us a a huge amount to help people
with the immediate cost of living and of
course we're going to do uh we're going
to do more but this is about tackling
some of the uh the mistakes of of the
past and making sure that we are set
well for the future and we're no longer
subject to we'll never again subject to
the the vagaries of the uh global oil or
gas price we can't be subject to
blackmail
as it were from uh people such as
vladimir putin we have energy security
here in the uk so it's a massive
strategy for uh delivering uh 50
gigawatts that's almost half the total
electricity capacity of this country
from offshore wind uh by 2030
totally reviving the nuclear industry
which i'm afraid has been more or less
moribund in this country this is the
home of nuclear energy we first split
the atom in the uk we had the first
civilian nuclear power plant we're
bringing nuclear home with one nuclear
plant and one nuclear reactor every year
for eight years rather than one a decade
what we're also doing is making sure
that we
take a sensible pragmatic view about
hydrocarbons we have domestic
hydrocarbons uh for the interim uh we've
got to uh make sure that we uh for the
interim people as we transition to
nature net zero we've got to make sure
that we use them sensibly as well and
and licensed stuff in the in the north
sea rather than uh importing in a higher
carbon uh fossil fuels from from abroad
from from russia amongst other places uh
but be in no doubt this is a massively
green strategy as well by 2030 95
of our electricity uh will be from low
carbon sources and and
talk about offshore wind what we're
doing offshore wind will be it will mean
we'll be able to power more than all the
homes
in this country just by offshore wind